good evening and James thank you for
inviting me to speak today I am NOT an
artist as you know from my introduction
and I guess wanted to tell you a little
bit about the field guides as from the
perspective of a user and also as a
person who accommodates artists I
actually always invite artists as much
as I invite scientists to visit the
Peabody collections and thank you and
get to meet and discuss certain problems
that artists face when they work on
field guides I also through my travel to
some of these places that most people
cannot point on the map I feel like I'm
contributing maybe a little bit to
better understanding of the ranges of
species and clarifying some of the
issues surrounding species limits that
James was alluding to so for example for
the country of Surinam there is still
not a bird field guide available so
that's definitely home for somebody to
fill I will mostly talk about bird
guides obviously because of this is a
vast area this photograph shows our
curator of birds and the professor in
the ecology and evolutionary biology
department rick brown in the field with
his students from the Orient ology class
helping them identify birds this is
Ecuador so the field guide is especially
chunky because that's one of the
countries with the biggest number of
bird species normally field guides are
defined as more portable small packet
size almost books or increasingly now
some digital devices that allow you to
identify plants animals or some other
natural objects in the field from a
distance frequently so it was quite a
challenge to find actually what would be
the oldest field guide available for
North America for example from some
online research I found this book by
Florence Miriam Bailey this
from 1889 and if any of you actually
over earlier examples I would love to
know this particular book it could be
called a field guide because of its
small size and because it explicitly
talks about field marks and using
binoculars the title birds through an
opera-glass implies that the optics will
be used and but the illustrations are
not particularly useful for fueled
identification some of some of the
people who actually work in the same
businesses myself like Frank Chapman
from the American Museum of Natural
History also attempted to create field
guides and sometimes called pioneers for
field guides to birds this particular
book is from 1924 what bird is that and
it actually shows immediately that he
most likely used museum collections to
generate these images you can actually
see that some of the purchase or exactly
as those you would find in museum on
museum shelves with taxidermy mounts the
idea of field guides this is a different
kind of art and especially the early
ones often group the subjects not
according to some sort of scientific
principle like phylogenetic relatedness
but often by overall similarity in the
example on the left you actually see
North American thrashes contrasted with
some other Browns tricky LBJ's as we
call them and those on the Left
represent at least four different
families I actually personally prefer
the ones organized phylogenetically but
I understand why for somebody who's a
beginner this would be an important way
to learn the birds this example on the
right is another way of doing this where
you actually group the birds by season
in this case these are all immature
Warblers as they would be seen in the
fall if you actually attempted to
identify that's one of the biggest
challenges to brothers in North America
and they as you can see are grouped by
those that have spots in their tails and
that don't and also by the stratum of
the forest so all these little clues are
great help when you actually attempt to
identify these this is a page from one
of the guides I used as I was growing up
back in poland by dessel burger and this
is what some people critique or call it
jokingly as a cookie cutter art but
amazingly this actually works pretty
well for bread identification in the
field having this kind of simplified
image and very predictably arranged
birds all face one direction you can
actually easily compare bill sizes and
tail lengths and so on so that actually
works well so the a different approach
to creating images for field guides is
to actually create scenes like sort of
museum dioramas where you actually put
multiple images of a species within the
context of their sort of average habitat
and this is an example from a European
bird guide by a Swedish artist class
Johnson with two species of owls that
share their habitat in up in Scotland
well Scandinavia and northern Europe as
all of you know here in North America
Roger Tory Peterson who's actually
native to Connecticut was needed lived
in old lyme we often considered the
father of modern field guides to birds
and in general too he popularized the
idea of field guides for other plants
and animals so his major innovation was
to include these arrows you could
actually see in the example of the left
from the original edition of his book
that these not only include the arrow
pointing to some most important thing in
his mind feature in the field to look at
but also explained with the text what it
is so it's not just pointing at the bill
but also says look at the color rather
than shape on the right this is from a
later edition and this is what we have
seen in the field guides for the last
maybe 30 years is to use these arrows
without the descript
putting a lot of more text in the the
pace in a opposite page to the plate I
actually prefer the other system and I
was really happy to see that this it
came it came back with the publication
of some of these new generation field
guides for European North America this
is my my most favorite field guide and
it's actually a work of two Brits and
too sweet Killian Milani and then
letters drummer the artist and these are
the people who for me earn a lot of
respect for spending a lot of time in
the field knowing the birds extremely
well and also being extremely familiar
with the I guess techniques to use to
depict these so some of the innovations
here in addition to these arrows and
text is that they also often put a
little inset with the habitat these
birds occupy I purposely put here these
drab birds because this is one of the
biggest challenges for identification in
the field this acrocephalus Warblers in
Europe and having these tools combined
with the descriptions of songs it these
slight differences in shape and some
features like primary extension how far
the primary feathers of the wing extend
beyond the turtles or secondaries it's
actually something that in the past was
used mostly only when you had a specimen
in hand but now increasingly with good
optics we can actually even use this in
the field so many of you might have seen
the Princeton oops edition of this field
guide and this is it has gone already 21
improved edition and this is once a guy
that I would recommend if you ever
travel to Europe or Middle East or
northern northern Africa the North
American equivalent is the Sibley guide
and this is david allen Sibley from
Massachusetts whose father was my
predecessor here at the Peabody Museum
and he single-handedly painted all birds
of north america in multiple the
is this is again what I love about this
new guides that these images are
arranged in a very predictable
systematic way where you have the adult
male in a predictable position so you
can easily compare species 80 species be
again sometimes certain features that
are included in insects are those
obscure little things that normally were
used only in hand now again you can
actually photograph these birds in the
wild and often see how wide the primary
feathers are and this is just one
example of many pieces of art that is
out there there now something in the
order of 700 field guides to birds
published these are some of the newest
pieces of art from our own Michael D
Georgia who's one of the artists who
visits the Peabody Museum and he
actually is now participating in a big
project illustrating all the non
passerine bird of South America with
guide Twitter and publicly so the plate
on the left is actually from this work
and it's not yet published but he allows
allow me to show this this is all based
on peabody museum specimens and
photographs and other resources that
these days artists use a lot of work
goes into this and one of the important
aspects of this work is visiting the
collections and actually seeing these
three-dimensional specimens james
mentioned the same thing for for some of
his artwork that he also likes to see
these physical versions so this is just
a study of the ivory-billed woodpecker
and james himself in the field on one of
these expeditions that we've organized
to the Peabody this is another good way
to get to know the birds and paint them
well so some of you may be wondering why
not use photography why go to all this
trouble when you already have to paint
these virtually every standard way
not much room for creativity why would
that is better to illustrate these field
guides with paintings and that's again
what something that James mentioned this
averaging in his oceanic fishes project
he mentioned that he would actually
illustrate them based on a single
individual and he actually cared that it
was this individual in field guides what
you actually would want is some sort of
average you actually look at a lot of
images or observe a bird in different
contexts and then summarize this all
into one image and it's really difficult
to do with photography here is an
example of one of the recent guides to
birds of North America by Ken Kaufman
and his attempt to show rushes for
something as brown as these trashes were
it's critical to know the exact shade of
brown and some features of the facial or
spotting some of this pattern it's
really difficult to show this in a
successful effective way and only slight
improvement is when you actually get
include multiple images of the same
species as Richard Crosley has done in
his recent field guide it's only last
year's book I invite you all to look at
this because some of these compilations
are really fantastic to look at but it's
not really a field guide it's a pretty
heavy 1.6 kilogram book that when you
would use put it in your car as you go
bird-watching and then refer to when you
come back from your walk and as you can
expect few guys are going digital this
is everything and by now you can already
choose among several options for your
phone apps you can actually the power of
these is that unlike paper field guides
you can actually have an option of
searching by vocalizations for example
you can keep your life list in the same
device you can submit records as use
encounter birds and there are very cool
ways of sort of dichotomy almost
dichotomies keys where you punch in what
you see color shape season state or
province and eventually it comes up with
very few
options of what this could be so in
conclusion I just wanted to invite you
to look at this website Diane Schmidt
out of university of sham was really no
in urbana-champaign she put together
this rather exhaustive database of field
guides to everything and you can see
from these categories I don't know if
you could actually read these numbers
but the birds she has said over 1200
guides and the second our clans with 721
wildflowers so I guess that's
representative that we're talking about
birds today and birds are still number
one for the field guides there is even
and there are some guides that you can
use to identify birth book or roadkill's
that's only half serious and if you are
going to some of those places for which
guides are not available there is now a
way to download images for example the
handbook of words of the world project
out of Barcelona Spain links editions
are promising to make available to to
subscribers all their digital image
versions of the images that they
generated in producing this series so in
the 16 volumes they manage to illustrate
all 10,000 species of birds of the world
so now you can easily use your iPad or
something to generate your own guide and
use it in the field so that's all I have
thank you very much